canicule sur l'europe on avait oublié
depuis quelques années qu'un mois de
juillet puisse être aussi chaud 31
degrés sous abri hier à paris c'est
carcassonne qui avait eu le record avec
35 degrés c'est un léger vent d'est
venus d'europe centrale et de la
méditerranée qui nous apporte cette
atmosphère tropicale
on aurait peut-être mauvaise grâce à
s'en plaindre au vu de ces images
les piscines refuse du monde
aussi plonge temps d'un peu partout dans
la seine
on enregistre une baisse sur la
chaussure
et une sérieuse hausse sur la bière à
toulouse apprend t-on on a manqué le
boissons fraîches depuis 14 ans il
n'avait pas fait une telle température à
cette époque de juillet et la météo nous
en promet encore pour 48 heures
une chaleur a douché les statuts
quant à ceux ci il reste à des
températures plus clémentes un froid de
canard peut-être
heureuse âge ou bien des libertés sont
permises en ces temps de tabous sur le
monokini à bordeaux on prépare des
traversées fantastique et chacun se sent
l'âme d'un tabarly
[Musique]
28 degrés seulement 27 à nice 33 à lyon
celle intervilles de la chaleur
le ventilateur est à l'honneur mais
l'éventail car de tout son charme
il fait chaud une température qui permet
tout de même bien des joies des joies
sans nom va rester la tête à londres et
les pieds au grand soleil
[Musique]